[Music]
thanks for coming how many of you have a
visual effects background or currently
working in visual effects cool nice to
see so many of you here at GCP next and
my name is Todd Primus I'm a product
manager on the media team at Google I've
been at Google about four years and I
work on solutions around content
creation so that's primarily rendering
and we're joined by Steve Kowalski Steve
is VP of systems engineering at Sony
image works he's gonna talk to you about
their pipeline their experience using
Google cloud platform and it's really
all under the guise of working with a
hybrid render farm as I'll talk to you
about in a bit we've we spent a lot of
time engaging with some of the really
large studios throughout the world for
visual effects rendering and we found
that all of them have significant
investment in their on-premise resources
so we've really taken the approach of
how do we offer an integrated solution
within Google cloud platform what are
the best practices to enable those
Studios to utilize their existing
on-premise architecture
first and foremost and then burst a
Google cloud platform is needed so all
obviously all of you are here you're
invested in learning more about GCP if
you're not already using it I don't need
to go through a lot of detail here but
the importance of cloud as a business to
Google is massive you can see the
investments we've made growing this I
remember my first GCP next four years
ago was a down third Street
I believe that way much much smaller
Crowder's to see see the business grow
see the interest grow from customers and
partners all over the world and even
within Google to see our organization
grow has been really exciting I'm now
I'm now a veteran in my fourth year at
Google working on cloud what I think is
of importance specifically to note
within our cloud regions where we
actually have compute capacity is our
close proximity the most of the major
media content creation hubs in the world
so think of the obvious places like
London LA Montreal Oregon for folks up
in Vancouver doing a lot of feature film
work Sydney Tokyo so all of these major
hubs were a lot of
content is created today have very close
proximity to Google cloud platform data
centers and this is useful for a number
of things first of all if you're doing
low latency NFS connectivity to mount
render nodes you can do that in all of
these locations we literally have a
customer in Los Angeles who's using our
le region for rendering they have a
leave is 1.4 millisecond ping from their
facility in Santa Monica to our LA data
center so literally when they spin up
render nodes it's as if those machines
are sitting in the room next to them in
addition remote workstations for artists
who are working either remotely in that
those cities or at those facilities is
something we can offer we work with
Nvidia on GPU offerings we have a
partnership with tera deechi for PC over
IP and their remote desktops and
actually if you'd like to learn more
about that on the third sorry on the
second floor of the Moscone West here we
have a complete virtual studio set up or
we have artists in on-site here we have
artists in Los Angeles and everyone's
working remotely off of workstations
running completely in the cloud on
Google cloud platform over the last few
days they've been putting together a 30
second animated piece using products
like Maya and B ray and an premiere of
editorial courtesy of our partnership
with bebop so they're putting together
this entire production live and in real
time utilizing an infrastructure and
resources provided by GCP so I think
when you take a look at this map take a
look at at the locations where we have
data centers and understand began the
importance of media and the media
vertical to Google cloud platform as a
whole and when I do talk about Google
cloud platform and our media solutions
obviously we're going to focus on
rendering and hybrid rendering today but
it is important to note that we're
looking to solve the ecosystem problem
or they provide the ecosystem solution I
should say really from glass to glass so
all the way from your content
acquisition when you're on set all the
way through to your final output
distribution utilizing platforms such as
chromecast and daydream VR imagine when
you're on set you're collecting
terabytes and terabytes of data how do
you get all that data quickly after the
cloud I mean we have a number of
different options we have something such
as partner interconnect or private
interconnect it allows you dedicated
connection to our network we also have a
transfer appliance a physical appliance
where you can literally load up to four
80 terabytes on to that and ship that to
us and get it on Google cloud platform
and all of the solutions in between and
obviously not all of you are working at
all of the different stages in the
production pipeline but we feel as
though through our software as-a-service
solutions our infrastructure and our
partnerships with leading providers of
tools that people are using today we
really do aim to provide the entire
end-to-end suite of solutions in media
and content creation all the way through
distribution and of course that's
augmented you know by our monetization
platform by things we're doing with ml
so again in media it's critical to us to
offer the end-to-end platform solutions
since this is a rendering talk I do want
to speak very briefly about sync render
it's something very near and dear to me
I've been working on it for seven years
and was actually involved in it before
before we joined Google it is our
software as a service completely managed
rendering solution and it's really aimed
at small to medium sized studios so what
we have is plug-ins that sit inside most
of the major content creation
applications and the idea is for studios
that don't have necessary the
development operations to set up a cloud
render farm or to manage licensing or
infrastructure assets synchronization
Zink really takes care of all that for
you it's quite an automatical solution
we like to say so literally you can be
inside of Maya using Arnold or Vee right
or render man wanna fire up a render
simply click on the sync plugin it
connects you to Google cloud platform
you can spin up up to 48,000 render
nodes complete with licensing all the
asset synchronization and your render is
taken care of care of things for you
we've been working on Zink for quite a
while now so we've tried to build more
and more complex tools into it in terms
of job predictability over cost in terms
of management for your files in terms of
permissions over how many users can
access which projects how many cores how
many resources so we're continuing to
develop this we've had some really great
progress with this we've had actually an
Academy Award nominated film which I
can't go into details yet I actually use
ink for for rendering so we feel like
we've been able to been able to enable
small to medium studios to really
leverage the power of cloud even if they
don't necessarily have the development
resources that the larger studios might
have I think it's also important to note
how we've strengthened our relationships
with most
the leading is fees out there in the
content creation space which initially
came from some of those Inc
relationships so if you're using zinc
now for rendering you can see we support
most of the major ISPs so products like
Maya 3d studio max render man Arnold
v-ray cinema 4d Houdini and and nuke
from the foundry we've also been able to
expand on these relationships with
several of these partners in the case of
KS group their v-ray cloud product which
is a plugin the asari a service that
sits inside of B ray next allowing
people to leverage cloud for rendering
is actually running on Google cloud
platform and the foundries athira
product which is their studio in the
cloud offering the complete suite of
foundry tools as well as some additional
third-party tools is also running on GC
P and that's a particularly interesting
product in the fact that it's again
designed for small to medium studios
that want to literally spin up a
complete workstation environment but
they can leverage GCP and it's a
completely managed service so all the
the studio needs or all the artist needs
is their laptop or a desktop thin client
and they can literally be working with
nuke or moto or katana in a matter of
moments all powered by GC P and as
you'll hear from Steve obviously GCP has
been been working wonders at Sony image
works we've also worked with a lot of
large studios throughout the world I'm
sure a lot of these names look familiar
to you but places like frame store and
MPC zoic studios we have the CTO of zoic
speaking a few days ago at one of our
leadership circle events talking about
some of the work that they've been doing
so the infrastructure is a service
offering from Google cloud platform and
our relationship with these really large
studios that are running exclusively in
a multi-class arena in a hybrid
environment between on-premise and cloud
is also really important to us and so
why is hybrid rendering important to
studios and why is it important to us
I've tried to break it down into kind of
the reality of what's going on today and
what we see the future as and I think
first and foremost it is the reality
that all of these studios have made
significant on-premise investments and
those investments are going to stay for
the next three to five maybe seven years
depending on how long they want to sweat
those machines out but it's it's not a
short game where everyone's going to go
ahead and take all of their on-premise
resources get rid of them and
and everything over to cloud so again
it's how do we work with these studios
to provide a hybrid environment that
allows them to utilize their on-premise
resources when it's appropriate and then
burst a cloud beyond that I think the
reality of it also comes down somewhat
to cost considerations when you're
talking about really large visual
effects animation studios that are have
projects planned for 12 to 18 to 24
months and they're running at 90-95
percent utilization the metrics in terms
of their cost on-premise and cloud it's
probably still somewhat slightly less
expensive to run on-premise first again
but we understand that we want to work
with these studios to help them to
enable more and more of their workload
over to GCP over time anytime you've got
a large studio oftentimes you're talking
about multiple locations so having a
unified pipeline management is critical
you want one queuing system that manages
your on-premise resources that manages
your cloud resources you want a single
machine image that you can run on
premise docker eyes that put that on GCP
and not have to manage separate versions
when you're running on prem versus
running on cloud so it really does come
down to burst capacity and Steve's gonna
share with you some stats and data on
how Sony sees the cloud and how they've
used us for bursts and ultimately we do
see this as the gateway to the future
again I'm not talking about the next two
or three years where everyone's going in
all cloud all the time you know but
imagine a future where literally you
have access to endless compute resources
anywhere in the world whether it's for
your remote desktops whether it's for
your render farm and think of the fact
that you can literally spin up a studio
you know anywhere in the world I mean
whether it be for for tax purposes or
for other business reasons and not have
to invest and set up an infrastructure
so it's still the very early days but I
think we've started to really
demonstrate the value of cloud in
working with a lot of these large
studios and so in terms of Google as an
infrastructure provider for for visual
effects animation rendering in
particular like what do we feel is is
strongest and I just want to highlight a
few of the things that are at our
fundamental offering level that that
Studios have shared with us is really
critical in terms of doing their
rendering work compute obviously it's
kind of the baseline core when it comes
to rendering and I want to call it the
fact we have a set of machines called
preemptable VMs or PBMs as they're
mainly referred to and that's probably
what I'll refer to them the rest of this
talk these are essential
the spare capacity machines and these
are available at an 80% discount of our
on-demand machines these machines can be
taken away if capacity is required from
another customer who's using them at
full price but I think for fault
tolerant workloads it's really the
Machine of choice for people doing
rendering one of the great things we've
seen out of most of the major renders
out there again when you're talking
about Arnold v-ray and render man is the
fact that they all have some sort of
check pointing or snapshotting mechanism
built in now so the fact is you can set
that up you can run a render and write
the partially completed frame back to
disk so in the event you're running a
machine for four or five hours let's say
you've got half the frame done and that
machine is preempted well if you enable
its neck snap shotting or checkpointing
you can simply pull up another
preemptable vm and resume the render so
you haven't lost all that so for fault
tolerant workloads such as rendering we
have really seen that preemptable VMS
are the this machine of choice we also
offer custom VMs so this allows Studios
to exactly tweak the VM size the kind of
job they need you can go up to 96 cores
for your RAM I started for your for your
CPUs and I believe it's over a terabyte
now for RAM so if you're doing a very
multi-threaded heavy Arnold or v-ray or
Enderman job you probably want to crank
to 96 cores if you're doing something
like a comp job and nuke that's not
threading quite as high maybe 16 cores
is adequate so we give customers and
Studios the flexibility to actually
configure VM to whatever they need
when I say massive size I'm simply
talking about the scale of our data
centers worldwide we have a customer
call called atomic fiction I've been
working with them for about seven years
now they were actually a zinc customer
many years ago and their co-founder Ryan
toad hope I think has a great quote that
I like to use you can have an iMac size
render farm at one minute and an ILM
size render farm the next so it's really
that ability to spin up and scale your
requirements on demand with literally
you know no no notice that I think makes
cloud makes our capacity quite
attractive to large studios looking for
burst capacity in terms of latest and
greatest we do offer the other skylake
machines and those machines can be spun
up very quickly so it's very fast
deployment you're looking at at 30
seconds or so when you actually boot up
a VM - when it comes online and so along
with our compute we now have GPUs
we have the the ka T's the p1 hundreds
of you and hundreds it just announced P
fours and all this can be used in a much
in a very flexible manner similar to our
CPUs so you get bare metal performance
you can attach multiple GPU counts to
any instance and depending on the kind
of work you're doing as I was mentioning
we have a wide variety of GPUs and again
I would really encourage any of you who
are interested in kind of the remote
workstation visualization side of things
just go down to - after this we have a
nice meetin entertainment section in the
solutions area and you literally see we
have three or four artists now working
all remotely using nvidia gpus and tera
dieci to run virtual workstations and
creating their their content storages is
obviously a very important part
especially if you're not doing an NFS
mount to a data center for close
proximity so if you're using our Iowa
data center for example from from LA or
from Vancouver it's important to note we
have a variety of different storage
options and of course much of the
rendering software today is legacy and
does require a POSIX interface so we
have all sorts of things I'm not going
to go through the entire list but if you
need you know caching there are products
that could be R there's pics cash cloud
file stores our recently announced
managed service for NFS filer and a
number of other options in there as well
our network I'm sure if you've been to
any other sessions today you've you for
this week you've heard our network
called out but it is the largest cloud
network and it's the fiber that we've
owned and we've laid and we've heard
certainly from large studios that have
locations throughout the world being
able to pass data once they've connected
to our network is just incredibly
reliable incredibly high speed so think
of studios that have offices in London
Mumbai Vancouver Los Angeles that are
now delivering shows in six to eight
months when they used to have 12 to 24
months the cycles to deliver are
compressing and the fact that you need
essentially these almost 24 hour work
times to to have multiple locations
working on a single shot it's something
that our network provides great
flexibility with email I'm not going to
go too much into this but I think we're
really starting to see some of our
customers especially when it comes to
visual effects content creation take a
deep dive in machine learning and really
want to understand what sort of
predictability can I have with cloud it
tends to be one of the major blocker so
you just first start engaging with the
studio like well we don't know how long
this is going to call
how much how much time it's going to
take and what we've seen more and more
our customers starting to look at the
data from past jobs and try to
understand and put together models as to
actually what is the cost for this
particular shot what is the cost for
this frame and I think as we start to
see more and more of these solutions
around ml come online that's gonna
alleviate a significant amount of kind
of the doubt and concern when it comes
to the unknown for cloud I want to wrap
up and talk a little bit about security
because it really is critical and we
were among the earliest cloud providers
to tackle this issue specifically for
feature-film Tier one content like to
say so what we've done is work with all
of the major Hollywood studios in terms
of working for approval regards to
allowing their most sensitive content to
be run on GCP so what we do is a
quarterly audit now with independent
security evaluators they're known as ISE
and they are the one of the cloud
auditors for Disney in particular and if
any of you have worked in feature film
you know that certainly the standards
required by Disney around cloud security
around on-premise security are are quite
high they are doing film and Marvel
shows Star Wars multibillion-dollar
films and making sure that content is
protected throughout the pre-release
process is really critical to them so
what we undergo is a quarterly audit of
GCP with ISE and that again is done
specifically for Disney we have a
redacted audit report that we share from
ISC with all the major studios so we
work through content protection
requirements with all of those studios
we've actually drafted a securing
rendering workloads solution which has
been published on our website and this
has been approved and vetted by these
studios which essentially is a step by
step very prescriptive guideline as to
how you as a visual effects vendor can
connect securely to Google cloud
platform when you're running your
rendering workload so again on top of
all the standard audits we do across the
ploud for for Google media entertainment
security and auditing specifically
working with the big studios is really
critical to us and what we will will be
working with in the near in the near
future is the trusted partner Network
and this is going to be more of a formal
consortium
among the major studios among several
other major content creator of providers
in media I believe it's among the MPA
and the CDSA and it's going to be one
standard audit that essentially is
similar to what we do now in terms of
the the requirements but to me again
more of a formalized version of that
that that assets Google cloud platform
can say yes we've undergone this trusted
partner Network audit for cloud and now
have approval from these studios so
that's about it for me right on time I'm
gonna turn over to Steve Kowalski who's
gonna share his thoughts on the image
works pipeline running on GCP thanks
Steve okay well thanks for everyone
coming out today I'm gonna apologize up
front for what may seem like a fairly
lengthy lead-in but I want to try and
frame the problem that we're solving by
using the Google cloud and I'm gonna
stick to my script on this because
there's a lot to get through and I want
to try and leave some time at the end
for any questions that you might have
and lastly I completely forgot about San
Francisco coffee and I had a cup of
coffee this morning and I'm surprised I
didn't jog to the arena this morning
because it's really got me amped up so
best istick stick to the script so okay
okay so my name is Steve Kowalski as
Todd said I run systems engineering for
Sony Pictures Imageworks I've been at
Imageworks for about 23 years now and
I've held just about every technical
position within systems engineering all
the way up to running the group I have
responsibility over the entire technical
infrastructure and also have
responsibility at our sister company
Sony Pictures animation in addition to
that I'm a Sony distinguished engineer
we've been working for with Google for
about eight years now where GC where GCP
customers
we're also G's
customers and that's how we we first
came into contact with one another we've
been talking to Google about rendering
in the cloud since before GCP was even a
product offering from Google so a really
long time at this point so image works
is a little unique within the post
production space and that it
simultaneously works on both visual
effects projects in full-length animated
features using the same production
pipeline so typically you work on one or
the other but not both and that's what
makes us unique we've been in business
for over 25 years have worked with all
the major motion picture studios on well
over a hundred projects at this point
we're headquartered in British British
Columbia in Vancouver have an office in
Culver City and run a large datacenter
in Quincy Washington at peak we grow to
about 1300 artists operate tens of
thousands of rendering cores and manage
multiple petabytes of storage so here's
a high-level picture of our wide area
network we've run multiple 10 gig
wavelength services that connect Seattle
Vancouver Quincy in Culver City we
operate our own MPLS network to provide
both redundancy and flexibility so you
can think of this as an MPLS cloud we
maintain points of presence in Vancouver
Seattle in Los Angeles and we currently
pier with Google in Seattle to reduce
the network latency back to our Quincy
data center we're also working on
establishing another peering
relationship in downtown Los Angeles
that we can take advantage of the new
Los Angeles data center all our projects
are bid and our fixed fee our workforce
tends to be ephemeral and scales up and
down and sync with the cyclical and
seasonal nature of our business by
cyclical I mean the times of year such
as the summer and the key holiday
periods in which large tentpole feature
films are typically released ultimately
these
seasons are what drive our computing
needs recently our schedules become much
more aggressive to allow filmmakers as
much flexibility as possible to make the
very best pictures unfortunately shorter
schedules means less time less time
means we need more people and more
people means we need more resources
often projects allow such little time
that the only way to get them done is
through sheer brute force so many
different types of artists work on a
movie and each follow the same basic
iterative process an artist uses
specialized software to create a script
of instructions for creating an output
submits that script to the render farm
to compute the output and then presents
the output to the director for feedback
the directors feedback informs the next
cycle until the director decides the the
output is just right a movies made up of
scenes and scenes are composed of
constituent shots groups of artists each
working in different disciplines such as
modeling layout effects lighting etc
make the necessary ingredients used to
assemble our shots each artist working
in each discipline is using outputs from
other artists to create iterations of
their own work for example a downstream
artisan lighting can't do their job
without layouts or inputs taken from
layout modeling rigging and animation
this process plays out over time until
the shots complete so why go to cloud
well for us what had been the typical
project is really no longer typical and
worse we can we can no longer count on
projects to start when they should and
more often than not they all run at the
same time so let's take a look at that
so not all artist disciplines have the
same resource requirements those who
come in towards the tail end of the
process namely those doing color and
lighting work tend to have the heaviest
resource needs and the least amount of
time to complete their work so from a
resource standpoint
every project becomes back-ended just
how back-ended a project becomes as
influenced by a number of variables
including script rewrites character
environment changes in decision you get
the point almost always though the
delivery date never moves so any of
these changes result in more work to
complete in a shorter amount of time and
something has to give in a perfect world
you work on multiple projects and they
time out nicely so you get good
utilization of your render farm and
maintain a steady artist base here we
look at three features running in the
same year each spread out in a
manageable way in a world like this you
can buy the rendering cores you need and
it's a good investment and this is kind
of what Todd was referring to earlier
lately though things have not been so
ideal and projects are piling up on one
another creating hiring challenges and
big resource shortfalls and this is
before anything unexpected happens on
one or more of the projects which is
something you can certainly count on
happening this has become the new normal
within entertainment so where does the
cloud come in well there's really two
parts to this one's defensive and the
other offensive on the defensive side
our resource deficits have become so
large that traditional procurement is
simply too expensive these shows require
upwards of 10 million dollars or more in
additional resources for periods as
short as four to six weeks in order to
finish the project at this scale few
companies are willing and/or able to
rent bare metal servers for such short
periods of time again we're talking a
few weeks here anyone who's willing to
rent wants to rent for multiple years
not weeks and the price is generally
very expensive the on-demand burst model
of cloud fits with our sporadic capacity
and flexibility requirements without us
having to make any commitment our
projects change literally from day to
day so that flexibility is really
important to us lastly with cloud
there's no physical infrastructure to
manage
which cuts down on the ancillary costs
associated with logistics installation
in ongoing operation on the offensive
end is speed looking back at the artists
cycle the quicker recycle the fewer
artists we need or the more work we can
take in or the more iterations we get
and we might even get a better picture
we also feel strongly that our
infrastructure should never be the
slowest link it's actually the one area
we have complete control and if we can
scale up resources to see if artists
time or give our clients what they want
when they want it we'll gladly do so so
why use the Google cloud platform well
we tried other platforms at scale and we
found success using them but for us
Google sticks out in a few ways a key
differentiator for us is Google's highly
performant network and infrastructure
Google really likes to point this out to
customers as Todd did earlier I always
thought of course they're gonna say this
why wouldn't they say this but it really
wasn't until we ran its scale and had
experience using other platforms that we
truly understood what they meant and it
turns out that they were right Google's
P VMs fit well into our rendering
methodology we launched an n1 standard
16 or an n1 standard 30 to PVM per frame
and all machines are the same meaning we
don't have to take what's available or
manage complicated bidding strategies we
choose what we want when we want and if
we ever need something custom we request
it and we pay a little bit more the
Google Cloud is simple straightforward
and for us has proved to cost as much as
50% less than other alternatives in the
market lastly the Google team
understands our business because the
network of support they've built is made
up of people who come from our business
and that's really important to us so
let's take a look closer look at our GCP
pipeline today our GCP pipeline is
modeled to support on-demand burst
rendering that's it that's all we do to
keep costs low we use only P VMs we
cache all data using a vir VFX T
clusters our instances spin up in under
30 seconds and are generally available
in our render queue in under two minutes
when we were preempted and we are
preempted we checkpoint er rendering
data and under 30 seconds we run only
Arnold renders and typically run 16 to
32 threads so we're simply doing ray
tracing here instances are treated as
ephemeral with all effort built into the
image rather than in post-processing and
we mostly launch the n1 standard 16
instances which provides 16 V CPUs and
60 gigabytes of RAM now here's a diagram
of what this looks like
q3 servers at SPI work in conjunction
with the provisioning system to launch P
VMs in TCP that read and write data
through a veer virtual caches for
management and orchestration a bastion
host is set up within GC P so we prevent
our admins from running g-cloud commands
on SPI machines logs are sent to
bigquery so that we can analyze use
later for billing purposes and the link
between SPI and GC P is a private 10 gig
interconnect with VPN and again for us
that's in Seattle our first burst
rendering project was the emoji movie we
started the project on AWS and we
finished it using TCP we ran for about
three weeks in GCP emoji was the first
time we ran in the cloud at scale and we
ended up growing much larger than anyone
had planned
we ended up growing to be about 5x what
we initially thought we would run going
into it so as a result we were really
unprepared and we learned a whole lot
from that experience and they were
really four main takeaways for us first
it was very difficult to tie the GCP
autoscaler
with our queuing system and we made some
real costly mistakes so we quickly took
over the necessary orchestration to
scale down
we needed to and that really helped us
curb runaway cost so you can imagine
going into a weekend and your cue clears
out and then your hosts keep running
until Monday morning and you pay for
that so that's a costly error second we
learned that we needed robust logging in
statistics collection so we always knew
what was running versus what the queue
thought was running there were times
when many more instances were running
than were in our queue again this became
costly so we wrote scripts to collect
data and pull our system third it became
clear that we could manage cloud hosts
like we managed bare metal systems
heavy-handed routine management simply
led to longer launch times increased
failure and larger than acceptable
numbers of instances failing to make it
to our queueing system so despite all
these challenges it was also abundantly
clear that this was going to be the way
forward for all our future needs using
cloud on emoji literally saved the
project we were able to double our
rendering capacity for a period of five
weeks and increase productivity of some
artist groups by as much as 2x which
that was huge eight months later we were
burst rendering again to finish Hotel
Transylvania 3 in all we ran for about
six weeks in GCP Hotel t3 was the first
show where we managed all orchestration
of our instances scaling them up and
down using our own scripts it's also the
first show where we strictly enforced
managing our image rather than the
individual instances using puppet and
young less management translated to
quicker launch times with less failure
we had to keep telling ourselves these
are P VMs they're ephemeral and in the
best case they're gonna live 24 hours so
there's no need to manage them once
they're launched but old habits can be
really hard to break this took a lot of
work on our part so I think there are
four main differences that I can
highlight from the
emoji movie the first is that we used
the n1 standard 16 instances versus n1
high CPU 16 instances it turned out on
this project we needed the extra memory
and we were ok paying a little bit more
for that second no bin packing was
allowed we ran a single job per instance
and threaded over all available course
this gave us the option to kill the
instance once the job finished again we
were aiming for a little more efficiency
here third as mentioned we introduced
our own scripts to scale up and down
automatically abandoning the GCP
autoscaler and lastly as I just also
mentioned we managed our image rather
than our instances reducing error and
improving overall efficiency the our
experienced cloud bursting on Hotel t3
turned out to be very different from the
emoji movie we introduced a new
rendering workflow that combined
persistent checkpointing with a custom
denoiser to cut a frame times by as much
as 45% as a result our instance group
side would size would often fluctuate
wildly depending on the time of day and
you know you can see you know peak times
for us were typically right before lunch
and right before people would go home at
night and I should note here to you on
this chart that we're measuring cores
and for us a core is equivalent to 2 V
CPUs right so but here you see the nice
sawtooth pattern and the cue loads up
with frames and empties out in a matter
of hours I should also note that during
Hotel T we no longer regulated how
quickly we scaled our instance groups so
you can see clearly in the chart maybe
you can at 6 p.m. on May 9th where we go
from 6,000 cores to over 20,000 cores in
one move those all launched in under 2
minutes this is really really powerful
stuff
so here's a breakdown of where the cost
landed on the show three quarters of our
total spent was allocated directly to
processing and that sort of felt about
right to us that comports with maybe our
traditional capital spending on on
infrastructure so seems right so today
right now at this moment we're burse
rendering on a project called small foot
and even though we're using the same
rendering optimizations introduced on
Hotel T our small foot experience seems
more akin to the emoji movie that's
because small foot has much heavier
scenes than did Hotel Transylvania and
the forty five percent efficiency gain
simply brings our frame times into
alignment with our historical trend so
there's one big change though the N one
standards 16s instance type lacks
sufficient memory for about half the
jobs we wanted to run so we launched
another instance group using the N 1
standard 32 instance type we created two
Q groups and our render technicians
simply tagged the high memory jobs to go
to the appropriate group now you might
be thinking why not run a high mana
instance well we looked at that option
and we determined while threading our
application over 32 V CPUs versus 16 was
about 17% less efficient the cost for a
high mem 16 V CPU instance was 25% more
than a 32 V CPU standard instance and I
think that's what's really great about
the Google Cloud there's always an
option to meet your specific need now
even though we only had a few weeks
between cloudbursting projects we were
able to make a few improvements since
hotel teeth first we introduced the
concept of unit testing and mandated a
full-scale test for any major change to
the system we also learned the hard way
to not assume that nothing had changed
between spinning down the environment
and spinning it back up again just
because it worked before doesn't mean
it's gonna work again so you really do
need to continually test second we
refined our queuing logic to more
quickly onboard cloud machines the lag
between instant spin up and queue
onboarding for prior projects really eat
into our overall efficiency now to be
fair on those projects efficiency was
not one of our main goals success then
was really simply measured by launching
an instance getting it in the queue
computing a frame and shutting it down
if we could do that
that was success and lastly as I
mentioned we introduced two tiers of
service the standard and high memory and
created tube queue groups to dispatch
jobs to now here's a cloud usage chart
for small foot in contrast to Hotel
Transylvania there's much more even
utilization over a similar
three three-day period the queue is
mostly full and that's because a portion
of the jobs tend to run much longer we
also believe the queue is doing a much
better job of dispatching new work to
instances that were nowhere near the 24
hour time limit imposed on all PBMs the
24 hour time limit is something you have
to manage imbalance with the risk of
preemption the longer an instance runs
the less chance ur is of preemption so
if your job runs for a short period of
time it's in your interest to keep using
that instance up to the point where the
timer will expire you need to fill this
out and act accordingly initially we
want it to compute a frame and kill the
instance it seems simple and
straightforward and felt like it would
be the most efficient thing for us to do
but many of our jobs would finish in
under five minutes so that proved to be
a poor strategy because we increased
both our overhead and preemption how do
our frame times Ben say 10 hours or more
it may not have been such a bad strategy
again you need to tell your approach to
your specific application and workload
now because small foots confidence in
GCP grew over the duration of the
project a week ago they doubled the
number of instances and now keep about
15,000 18,000 cores busy almost 24/7
when combined with on-prem resources the
total number of course small foot can
keep busy is well over 50,000 when I
last checked they were computing 600,000
frames a day they'll deliver the project
sometime in the next three weeks now
here's the preak down of where the cost
of landed thus far on this project it's
not too dissimilar from Hotel t3 by
percentage of total spend there's
slightly less net work and a little more
cash in processing Hotel t3 rendered
about 40 percent more frames daily than
the small foot so this seems reasonable
to me alright so I'll wrap up by sharing
what the next steps are that we intend
to take with cloud there are five areas
I see us focusing on in the near term
the first one and perhaps even the most
important is around socialization
stakeholders at all levels within the
company need to understand what the
cloud is the benefits it brings the
potential business enablers and how it
can be used to change the most
everything we do in the three projects I
discussed at first each team was very
skeptical about using cloud and by the
end of their projects all had become
evangelist
our senior management producers
supervisors artists and developers all
need to understand how the responsible
use of cloud computing can help the
business reach its goals quickly
efficiently and without any sacrifice to
quality socializing cloud within the
company is very important and something
we will continue to put a lot of effort
towards it's also important to socialise
cloud within the larger industry so that
even our clients are educated on what
the benefits of using it are efficiency
we're pretty efficient once we get an
instance managed by our keyring system
but we have some work to do
on the logic that we use to
turning weather to shutting instance
down or dispatch another frame when a
job completes we're also not as
efficient as we could be managing the
full lifecycle the instance so that's
another area for us to focus on
orchestration we'd like to orchestrate
the render environment directly from the
queuing system after all the queuing
system is the thing dispatching the work
to these machines and we figured doing
that would allow us to pick up as much
as 10 to 15% in overall efficiency
monitoring and logging well we do
extensive logging and statistics
collection on the jobs when you run in
q3 we want to better understand the full
picture so that will incorporate more of
what we log to bigquery and stack driver
into our daily reporting I see these
stats feeding into some custom dashboard
that we can specifically tailor to each
viewer and then there's reach we'd like
to extend our rendering reach beyond us
us West which will involve pushing some
pipeline servers into the cloud to
mitigate the additional network latency
running multiple zones reduces risk
especially as our resource requirements
continue to grow a little further out we
see other areas we can leverage cloud to
enhance and grow our business and Todd
was sort of alluding to this towards the
end of his talk first is is perhaps the
most obvious which would be to expand to
a full studio pipeline in the cloud and
I think there's four kind of key parts
to this step first is to expand our
rendering to include more types of jobs
effect simulations and compositing are
two big areas for us cloud workstations
to accelerate workflows and enable new
office locations and or mitigate the
inevitable surges in labor often
required to complete projects dialing in
performance on workstations will allow
us also to pursue more real-time
workflows at the desktop storage will
use cloud file store and other
third-party storage options to migrate
our data and extend our pipeline into
the cloud our pipeline is NFS based and
our applications require
posix-compliant file system and we don't
expect that to change anytime soon
lastly there's our pipeline will migrate
our middle tier and pipeline servers
into the cloud and rewrite applications
to scale up and down on demand or run as
micro services and a lot of these
applications have been written and
assumed that the machine is just on 24/7
so it's difficult to just swing these
things over to cloud now if we can
enable a full studio in the cloud we can
add additional office locations when our
clients and our projects require us to
do so we could truly become a global
company and leveraging Google's global
network will allow us to do it quickly
and on terms that we set it's really
important there are also great exclude
great solutions to explore around backup
disaster recovery and business continue
ants increasingly with the sheer amount
of data that we generate traditional
tape backup no longer meets our needs
god forbid we lose a file system on one
of our our servers our only recourse is
to try and piece it back together again
from probably hundreds and hundreds of
tapes it's just not gonna happen
in time and finally the Google beyond
Corp tools that are available today
allow us to set up cloud-based Identity
Management these can be leveraged in
conjunction with cloud cam mass to
secure the data we move into the cloud
and implement multi-factor
authentication on any web-based
application using the identity aware
proxy service we use the ia P today to
extend flex which is a collaborative
story development application from the
foundry to remote Sony Pictures
animation users it works great and it
mitigates the need for cumbersome and
complicated VPN based solutions so
that's all I've got for you guys I want
to thank you I wish you luck in using
the Google cloud if you have any
questions please feel free to reach out
to me at this email address and I think
we got a few minutes for questions if if
anyone wants to
up to the microphone so they can they
can get the audio okay thank you thanks
to you yeah thank you
[Music]